that's very true there are very few
those sort of I guess you'd call them
fringe people whatever I was more like
that and I I relate a lot to the
character of Ivan um what can you tell
us about Ivan from from you read the
script I haven't no I haven't read it oh
really okay well um you should but I've
been I really like Ivan I relate a lot
I've in myself because I mean when I
first started attacking and I realized
that he's the one character who was like
heart it's just too big for the world
that he's living in who like um has too
many feelings and is never able to
express himself basic things that
teenagers go through but for him it's
much more amplified because he feels so
much more um so that's basically how he
started writing him as this like little
like you know wanna be skater kid like
doesn't really fit anywhere to begin
with and finds himself and a group of
friends that don't respect him and like
use him and he's in love with this girl
and has loved her forever but you know
it just would never work because she's
you know in a different world than he is
and you know and then his illness like
his schizophrenia all comes into play
she's a very sensitive I kind of based
him on my vision of Kurt Cobain actually
when I wrote it oh wow yeah that's great
I'm sorry I didn't cut you off yeah I
was just like you know it's just like
blond kid so I sort of imagine like what
would it be like for Kurt to grow up I
was like a kid and you know feeling all
the things that he felt and then you
know he also ended his life in like a
very dramatic way so I just kind of
worked from there one yeah I know David
always cheers me talk about these these
random Kurt Cobain interviews that I'll
find online one of the greatest things
that he talked about was that here are
these kids I guess that he grew up with
in Washington state that didn't like him
at the time and then he becomes the lead
singer of Nirvana and all the sudden
ease worshiped and now they're like
coming back to him and
just like this thing like they didn't
like me then you know why do they like
me now so I've always liked fall
occurred as well and I've loved you know
his sensitivity and it is a very sad
story and he was you know very
misunderstood so when I guess that's
what I like about Ivan's character from
the little that I know and also do I
think Ivan sort of retreats into this
dream world is that right about what his
idealized dad would be like yeah he does
and uh you know like especially like in
the younger version of Ivan like the
world of like the military fighting
where you'd like puts on his dad's
jacket you know so that he can feel like
he's a part of that world somehow and
that continues his entire life I think
that's why he's also sort of detached
from a lot of the things that are
happening like when he sees them
immediately because we just sort of like
keeps them inside and save them for
later you know